joining me today is a comedian a writer
for The Daily News in the spectator the
former sex columnist at playboy and a
woman in the midst of taking off Twitter
for Lent Bridgette a tizzy welcome to
the Rubin report thank you for having me
you are in the midst of taking off
Twitter for Lent as I just said you are
you are on a break from little
characters and attacking people and
owning people getting annoying people
and getting attacked I know exactly how
is it going before we get into anything
else about you I mean how so first of
all how long you've been doing it for a
couple weeks okay yeah so I
inadvertently didn't know that this was
of the line just lent ever so it's
normally 40 days but because of the way
Easter falls it's 46 days oh man and I'm
there's 26 days left some 40 days or
sorry 20 days end right of my 46 which
is oh why Twitter why giving up Twitter
of all things so I have not many vices
left I've given up drinking I've given
up smoking weed I've given up I mean if
there's something you can quit I've
pretty much quit it other than coffee
and Twitter and I thought that I would
give up coffee because that was the
easiest of the two and I tried and so I
decided that I would give up Twitter and
I I'm like you I take weekends off
sometimes I try and I felt in February
really addicted to it I'm I remember
there would be days where it I'd say
okay 9:00 a.m. you're off you shouldn't
even be doing it in the morning but by
9:00 a.m. get off and go do something
and then it's 11:00 and I'm like well
I'll just do until 11:00 yeah and then
it's noon and then and this is very
addictive thinking oh well I've already
ruined my whole half of my day so now
just until the rest of the day I'm just
going to tweet and I can feel myself
that refresh refresh refresh like a
little rat what was that like when you
realize that the kick that you're
getting don't believe kick or whatever
it is is sort of like some of the things
that you've quit because you've been
you've been sober for about five years
yeah not five and a half a little bit
who's
and the it wasn't necessarily noticing
the kick it was noticing the inability
to the lack of powerless a feeling kind
of powerless over being able to stop
when I wanted to stop if I put an end
time not being able to meet that end
time having it I it's very much like my
life started getting a little bit
unmanageable yeah things are and even
just seeing how much the most
interesting thing that's come of the two
weeks or little more than I guess almost
three weeks now is how much physical
energy I have so how this and this I
haven't really found the science on
because I'm a nerd so I went down all
these science holes and now I'm looking
at reading this book irresistible which
is all about screen addiction and all
the studies and it's brilliant but why
do i how is something so passive taking
so much energy actual physical energy so
you physically feel better Oh physically
I have so much actual energy and is it
just because the adrenals you're getting
kind of fired up when you have that
adrenaline I don't know how you feel
when you're on I generally step away if
I start feeling reactive yeah if I'm if
I start feeling my heart racing and even
when I'm kind of addicted I'm like okay
Bridget yeah what about the mental
clarity so that's been I the
productivity is I've written I've been
doing a daily writing prompt on my
patreon I've written up just that alone
I've done 15,000 words I wrote a 12 page
book proposal I did I've been keeping
diary of a Twitter junkie adjust the
daily how I feel and whatnot and that's
another probably 20,000 word I'm pretty
much written a book yeah I mean that's
why you're doing it it's about the same
amount that I probably would have
written on Twitter Yeah right exactly so
it's interesting because when I've done
this and as you know I do the weekends
and I do the August thing and what I
found is especially when it's not just
the weekend when it's the longer one is
that I'm just generally kamar like I'm
not bad
erotic or whatever in general okay but I
find that like like my patience level
like if I'm at the supermarket you know
normally you're like checking out and
you're maybe looking at your phone or
whatever where now it's like I'm more
inclined to say hello to the person
that's checking out or just like a
little more present I'm so much more
present definitely that that has been a
remarkable difference and everything and
even people in my family and my sister
we were joking about the other day and
she said and then you are more present
even just on the phone with her and in
my life and I feel like even my dog
notices that it's just my dog see
marketed to me like it's because I'm
just not on my phone all the time and
it's the but I'm a maniac I have an
addictive personality and I'm just a
maniac in general and so the first week
I would say I went through real
withdrawal and it was interesting
because I went to I went to Mass on Ash
Wednesday because I figured if I was
gonna do it I might as well partake in
my ritual mhm I'm not some great
Catholic but I went and I was feeling
kind of ashamed that I was quitting
something so stupid as Twitter and the
priest or the Monsignor gets up and he's
giving his sermon and he says Lent means
slow and French and that it means this
is a time we're supposed to go with then
and look at how we can help those who
are suffering and and he said we need to
slow down and then he reaches under his
cassock and he pulls out his cell phone
and holds it up in front of the whole
parish and says and put these down yeah
and I looked around and I was like we
have a problem Society when a priestess
is holding up itself is very telling you
to put it down it's like destroying your
relationships here and that was a cover
of my ad who's on her phone and the
church is hilarious well it's
interesting because it's like we can't
quite quantify how having access to this
much information so fast just out of
nowhere basically only within the last
day 10 years we have just no idea how
it's rewiring our brain the way we think
the way we behave the way
yeah they're well they do all these
Studies on empathy with younger kids and
how that's you need to have those one of
the things about the world we live in
even just canceled culture etc I feel
like there's this diminishment of being
awkward
you can't nobody is allowed to have
these awkward interactions which is how
you you might say something wrong and
then somebody will have a look on their
face and you know oh I went I stepped
over a line but because everybody's
living in so much fear of saying the
wrong thing or they're there there isn't
this like awkward or they're just on
their phones where they can have text
message interactions and I hear tone and
body language so there's this loss of
making mistakes and being awkward and
even I'm and you see it all across the
board right now yeah so that that's been
it has been interesting just if you sit
in a restaurant and you are say you and
I went to eat and you went to the
restroom and I just sat there and did
not look at my phone I would look like a
psychopath yeah oh my god she's just
sitting there and this in the book
irresistable he says that there's this
inability for us to just be bored that
as humans we used to just have this idle
time and I look at my screen time and
you know you'll see your screen report
and it'll say something like Oh
your screen time is accounted for you're
like hooray and then it's like to five
hours right to 27 hours a day
what am i doing for five and the number
of times you pick it up I were rats
relieved rats is the catch-22 though
that the internet and all this
connectivity has also given us I mean I
can talk about just the two of us we
look at the digital space and we've
created things that people appreciate
and all those things it's also giving us
everything that we want in a certain way
like I'm so appreciative of my life and
it's through that connectivity I know
but that doesn't mean it's not a
dangerous sword to wield I suppose and I
would feel so isolated ideologically and
and in 20 2016 approaching 2016 being in
LA I started feeling like I was going
crazy I truly yeah and it was you and
people finding people like you online
and that's how I kind of came out of the
space of I would say I was just living
in the on Twitter I was really just
around comedians and writers and then
slowly kind of drifted into political
Twitter which was always there yeah now
you're full on all right I'm happy to be
inducted into this club yeah all right
so let's let's go there for a second so
one of the things that the reason that I
wanted to have you on for quite some
time is I've sort of been watching
through Twitter your your what I would
say political awakening is because you
strike me as just a sort of old-school
lefty liberal yeah whatever but you are
seriously waking up to or have woken up
to just the the postmodern thinking and
left this nonsense and all of this stuff
about free speech and we'll talk about
me too in the piece you wrote and and a
series of other things like it seems
like every day I can see you getting
like a little more this is the problem
so I have I have to check myself and
these are the questions like that I
would have for you for instance as
somebody with what I thought were
liberal values I I don't like how in
this tribal world
it's like the left get social justice
and the right gets Family Values know
though is everybody should care about
those things I know plenty of people on
the right who care about social justice
and plenty of people on the Left who
care of how family right well how would
you define social justice when you say
that um oh gosh I
I mean I think just caring about other
people I feel like there's an idea that
people on the right are callous and just
don't care about it right they only care
about taxes right money and themselves
and and essentially art there's a
callousness I would think that is of
applied to that but I think that people
I'd found that to be completely untrue
but the more that I've met these people
I think I did think that years ago so my
biggest thing that I have to
myself is am i reacting to rejection so
in being somewhat rejected by the former
party although I don't feel rejected I
feel like I didn't move it just went you
know they're drifting away yeah and I am
I kind of I explained it to people like
I was this customer of regular at a bar
and I was a regular at the bar and then
they took me as the voter for instance
and they and I just kind of went to that
bar all the time they knew me I grew up
going to that bar with my grandpa and my
dad yeah it was a family bar tradition
and then suddenly they stopped caring
about me and they started caring about
the hipsters of the beards and craft
beers and stuff and they stop caring
about just their regular customers and
the normal common sense folk and started
making these fancy drinks I like this
metaphor I like this metaphor they
somehow last me as a customer because
now I am a registered independent and
you'll see the criticism of on the left
I see this a lot of well somebody said
something I didn't like and so I stopped
believing in and you know equality and
women's rights and I abandoned all of my
principles and became a conservative and
I don't I don't think that's a fair
assessment wait that assessment I think
has no self reflection which is my
biggest eye that's really people accused
me too they say oh you don't call out
the right enough well I'm not a
conservative yeah I don't know anything
I'm learning about conservatism but I
didn't know anything I didn't I was
irate I was raised as a blueblood Yankee
Democrat liberal my parents sang for the
cat my dad sang for the Kennedys like
that was where I came from
yeah and so coming I just wasn't really
paying attention and then suddenly I
felt like that what's happening how are
these how how is it that they're you
know it's suddenly like punk rock to be
conservative all right all right I want
to back up to this
Barr's metaphor I like what you're doing
here so okay now the hipsters come in
they've got their fancy drinks you know
you're you don't know where you are
anymore the bar that you and your dad
and your grandpa are in where do you go
so you walk out of the bar what happens
now buddy out right
what are you shocked when you go into
the other bar next door that you thought
was the evil bar and you realize that
well there's some decent people in this
in this crazy conservative ya world
people are people I'm always like are
you
I moved every year and a half growing up
so I'm very sensitive to mob mentality
in general I'm very aware of groups and
how they like to form and tribes and
I've always been the girl on the outside
kind of looking it and so this space
that I'm occupying now is not really
that unfamiliar to me but what was
shocking was finding that it they
weren't evil these like evil people and
that their values you know we can have
differences of opinion and that seems to
be the thing that concerns me the most
is that there doesn't seem to be any
tolerance for different differing
opinions or nuance which is what's
worrisome and so the new bar seems to be
a little bit more tolerant however I'm
also aware that they're more than happy
happily they will more than happily
weaponize somebody like me as like the
disaffected liberal who no longer you
know who was rejected from her tribe
essentially nothing that true they
weaponize how people say that to me
we'll see you left the left and now the
rights embracing you because they just
they want to use you to show that that
you're not that bad or that they're not
that bad or something like what I mean
they don't seem to be that bad no it's
true but what I mean by weaponize is
that they'll happily abandon me if I
don't it's not like they're taking me in
as one of them
yeah so they're not taking me into their
tribe for it to protect me and the
minute that I express any nuance for it
for in anything that might not be in
alignment with them there there will be
no defense of me I'm pretty I bet that
will change I bet your thoughts on that
will change yeah because I go to all
these conservative turning-point College
events and I talked about being
pro-choice and gay married and pro weed
and for strong prison reform and the
death penalty all these lefty things and
they keep inviting me back they love the
difference is that I mean that's really
what I'm fighting but I hear you that's
weird is weird to think that's possible
when you're in that new bar yeah but
that's just what I found I found they're
more open-minded and I can have these
discussions with openly about things
that I didn't feel like they're again
there was not room for discussion and
there have been just the the most my
awakening really came when I started
noticing that I was self censoring so I
just started recognizing that I was not
speaking freely and even when I went
into Michael Knowles show I remember we
were all just makeup and talking and I
was like ah it's so nice to be able to
just speak freely and not be walking on
eggshells and afraid that I'm gonna use
the wrong term or what wrong anything
and just that recognizing that that was
happening was something that pushed you
know I would say was where not only was
I ignore it at the bar but suddenly I
was not sure I wanted to be in that bar
and yeah yeah because I felt like I
wasn't really welcome and part of me is
am I just old and maybe I'm like the old
lady that's like this isn't the way
danger my god I'd seriously hoped I'm
only two years older than yeah you know
I mean there there is a certain amount
of stuff that I've learned from younger
women where they've their the whole
stuff of consent culture for example I
think that again it's it's eroding a lot
of awkwardness and the like can I touch
your hair yeah
and just human sexuality trying to put
that much control on it is crazy to me
however they the younger women are like
just cuz you old bags put up with like
somebody smacking your ass while you're
waitressing doesn't mean that we have to
and okay fair enough but that's
different than the consent culture right
yeah I think most most decent people I
think probably most of those scary and
conservatives in that bar they're
probably not slapping waitresses ass in
that bar actually you know what they're
secretly doing it in the first bar you
were at the same time they're pretending
that they got women and kids all across
the board though I mean I've experienced
that yeah that's that's just I would say
yeah it's it's I think my point was
really that I just probably turned my
head to a certain amount of sexual
harassment like that the younger
generation just doesn't accept which is
not a bad thing so where do you how do
you you've written about this a little
bit how do you draw the lines on all
that what you're describing is just sort
of basic human emotion with each other
and that we need a certain amount of
freedom and ability to make mistakes and
push each other and and that we have
certain desires and that you know but
they can't be just like unbridled
desires and all of that with a culture
now where you know they want you to
assign documents before yeah and there's
apps where you both have to consent
we're gonna do this in sign can be
withdrawn retroactively Lee I think you
can still look back and say oh no I
didn't come we're going to consent
there's that ridiculous story from like
a year ago I forget what school it was
we're both students the male the female
after accused each other of rape ah
they both accused each other because
they wanted to get the leg up on the
other one quick like that's how so how
do you how do you manage that mean if
someone that writes about sex and all
this stuff how do you how do you
negotiate I mean this was part of the
reason that I I think again when you
want to talk about awakening I was the
girl that was writing for flavor way
like it was still the 90s because I I
didn't go to college
and so I didn't have the indoctrination
of a lot of this woke culture I'm not
woke at all and I would say things like
in my first article
it was women date [ __ ] because
you're a [ __ ] and it did not go over
well left or the right that was the
first time that I was like mutually
getting so what was the hate you were
getting from each the men's rights
activists and stuff we're saying like
that men don't generally like being
called [ __ ] as if you if you can't if I
mean essentially they're like oh so if I
can't get laid I'm a [ __ ] you know like
that screw you and then that it was like
toxic masculinity
I'm Allah from the like extreme
feminists and that happened to me a lot
they extreme men and women often I don't
think they realize how close and the
circle they are well what do you make of
that whole situation right now that it
seems like at some level we're entering
like this low Great War of the sexes
like you sounds like a bizarre dystopian
story no I know and it's I I don't think
that so I don't think you need to
emasculate men in order to empower women
and I feel like this is kind of the
there's so many double it's like okay so
you're talking to me about toxic
masculinity and you're saying toxic
masculinity this and men can't show
their emotions oh but sit the sit down
and shut up
actually we don't want to hear from you
at all guys unless you are a a trans man
or unless you are a person of color
who's gay are you check some boxes we
you're allowed to speak but other than
that if you're a white male like shut up
yeah well where does that volunteer
toxic masculinity and how is that
helpful how because from my experience
writing for men and hearing from men
says hetero men like the alpha male and
my kinda dude they are struggling you
know they've they're I I would I did
some some of my favorite pieces where
pieces like I'm balding or
premature ejaculation and Men I'd say
hey guys what do you think about this
and it would be essays thousands of
words no one's really asking them
questions how they're doing and when you
do ask them hey how are you doing it's
like a fountain of pain essentially yeah
it's so fascinating to me because as you
know I've been on tour with Jordan piers
yeah last year and it's like people
always say it's angry young men coming
to his shows and I don't find them to be
angry but they are people that are
trying to put their lives together but I
always think it's such an odd criticism
because let's pretend it was 90 percent
angry white cisgendered toxic men and he
was helping them deal with some of their
issues that would be a good thing right
so the blanket accusation of oh we you
know you're just writing for straight
white men or that it's mostly straight
white men that show up to these things
I'm not even saying that the case it's
it's such a low-level argument because
everyone needs help regardless of their
gender or their skin skin color yeah and
people are you know women have been
given I feel more tools and they they
just are allowed to express themselves
emotionally in society and men really
aren't and so it they don't have tools
they just don't have as many and they
don't feel as comfortable opening up I
don't feel like men particularly feel
comfortable opening up even to other men
although they might be getting better at
that but it does seem like they'll open
up to me because they feel comfortable I
also I just don't really judge anyone
for whatever they they come to me with
and I'm certainly not judging someone by
the color of their skin or by whatever
their politics might be because I feel
like first we have to meet as humans and
I feel like we're all just on this same
kind of sinking ship together and you
know it's like fighting over the last
seat on the Titanic like what why are we
what is how is this helpful I don't see
the discourse right now being helpful
and I don't see how you basically taking
an entire group of people and saying sit
down and shut up is is helpful it
Howard's oppressing a whole another
group of people
how is it doing the same thing that you
was done to you how does that help Wow
I was having a lunch meeting with
somebody just about some business stuff
and but he didn't actually know that
much about my politics right other than
what I do and we had this really good
meeting and then at the end something
about politics directly came up and he
started saying this thing about how it
should be all women we should give scare
rid of all men in politics and it should
be all women is all about and we have to
topple the patriarchy and I thought hey
you're talking about you he was a white
man and so you're talking about taking
yourself down he was also struck me as
very successful probably in there like
you're you're like want to take all that
down but also what are you actually
saying so it's not inherent that if you
just had all women doing things that
things would be better but that seems to
be the weird place that we're in I
wouldn't I don't think things would be
better if we only had men doing it
either no and again like used to go back
to your point about the War of the sexes
we are which is also a weird thing to
just because of all the gender stuff too
it's like this weird war of the sexes
that's occurring under the the idea that
gender is a social construct I'm like
like I'm losing my mind and I think a
lot of people do just normal people my I
mean I did a piece or I'm doing working
on a piece and I asked people to email
me like how are you being so son how are
you self censoring what I saw when you
did this on Twitter yeah yeah and got
immediately everyone was like don't
write this piece and okay you started
getting attacked by blue check verified
journalists saying don't write this yes
journalists telling other journalists
not to write a piece it's crazy but it's
like it's like comedians please doing
other comedians for jokes this is
another thing that I'm like are you
kidding me guys when when did you become
like I remember when everybody on the
right was getting mad about rap music
like how is this the how are you then
yeah you literally have lefty comics
calling for books not to be poet I mean
it's it's not so I and a lot of these
mommies are getting shamed out of mommy
groups because they're not playing by
the
nerd thing or they don't understand it
or they're just trying people are just
trying to catch up and change in like
one year yeah and so one woman was
writing me that um she went to get a
birthday president and she walked into
the store she lives in a liberal you
know I think she's on the East Coast in
New York somewhere and she said oh I can
you wrap this for a girl and the woman
oh she said you would have thought I
asked for and the woman was like we
don't do that here
excuse me we have brown we have white we
have gray you don't wrap for a gender
and she was rude to her about it and
only he said white you know she didn't
know and this is turning and I think
this is why I scream to the to the left
the most yeah is that they don't
understand that they're pushing people
away how much weight do you think is
just that they they have this thing
where it's like if you don't accept what
they accept as true the second they
accept it you're the bad guy so if you
don't come around to exactly how they
are on transitions right now you know I
mean even if you're you're respectful of
trans people and you're really trying to
understand these issues and understand
gender and sexuality and all these
things but if you don't do it the second
stage of it if you don't come around to
gay marriage the second they do it you
know let's not forget Barack Obama is
not for gay marriage yes I'm here and
history will not be too kind to him by
these people yeah it's the I don't most
people don't even know they're just
there and they kind of stumble into
these into these inadvertent my friend
for example who did my makeup she said
she said my kids are coming home with
fully formed opinions about Trump
they're 8 and 11 that she's not giving
them she said so where are they getting
these opinions I had a family member who
is she freaking out about that I mean is
she just she says you know everybody
they have conversations about it in
their home she did make up for somebody
she posted a picture of herself in an
occult search like hey look who I did I
stumbled into and she said she got
completely eviscerated on Facebook and
didn't even see it coming so I think a
lot of people have when they see this
you know these kill shots that they
always go that everybody swarms and
other people observe this and the public
shaming and then it silences them so
every time these little and we don't
know how many of these little micro
shammies are occurring all across
America and what worries me
well not worries me but what's
interesting to me is how many people
there are like me who have and you know
people are coming from the right as well
for their own reasons and now they're
you know independence they're basically
like well I am there's crazy stuff on
both sides and I believe in common sense
and reason and nuance and free speech
and the you know scientific method and
yeah I had a dream last night actually I
was nervous and I had a dream that I was
on the show and I said I'm coming in
Dave I think I'm on Twitter and it is
liberating because I don't have to hear
anything and I can say anything like
boys and girls are different yeah and
usually go dream or like don't say that
well you're welcome to say it in reality
but the beauty of this is so when we
post this episode god only knows what
you've said already that offend the
masses and you won't even know for weeks
but your cousin
what's your name Maggie your cousin max
is running your Twitter account now and
and sharing some stuff and all that so
do you think there's any chance that
some kind of new center can develop here
I think there I'm optimist I red run
optimistic I generally think that I hope
I saw I saw Clara's interview and you
know she was saying we have to share the
risk and I
yeah yeah mm-hmm I love that idea of
sharing the risk that but I also have
nothing to lose I don't have children in
school who will be punished by my
politics by their teachers I mean one of
my family members during the election
she had you tell her kids her teachers
were insane because of this stuff they
were coming home and telling her and
they were crying and you know these are
adults who are supposed to be teaching
children it she's just thought I had to
tell them like your your your teachers
aren't saying what your basically
sending your kids to a mental
institution all day long and then you
bring it over you go wacko and so I
don't have and I'm not working in a
corporation where I have a job that I
could lose I don't deal with HR thank
God because that sounds like a nightmare
but you don't have nothing to lose
because you've got writing gigs and
you've got well either way they you
support yourself I mean that the mob can
come for anybody right like it's oh it's
not nothing but people I guess I'll
probably never know somebody like me
will never know what I've lost so for
instance I don't know what doors have
shut I know that my politics on Twitter
will keep me out of writers rooms for
sure yeah and I know and I actually know
that for a fact that even somebody
looking for someone who is somewhat
centrist but that I was too far right
which is right well that's what they do
to everybody that's the investment I
mean it's so I know I don't know that
some showrunner won't see my Twitter and
say no forget that girl she's a Nazi
mm-hmm I I do know that I had a really
brilliant editor Joe Donatelli he was my
first editor a Playboy and he said die
on your own sword and I love that
because that really is all that I can do
and all that we can do and the great
thing about the Twitter hiatus has been
really being able to step back and look
at the big picture and perspective and
the bigger themes that keep coming up
within these little mini micro outrages
and news cycles that we get all juiced
up by and one of those is free speech I
will die on that hell
hell I will die I'll be right there with
ya I will die on that hill and I and
that was the biggest thing that I saw
you know I have art to Vanna he has
amazing profiles with people that nobody
will publish because they're just
considered talks like everyone that was
a great writer we were talking about it
right before he wrote a he happened to
write a really nice piece about me and
playboy where where he was also critical
of me and it was but he's an actual
journalist and I thought yeah it took a
lot for me to be willing to let him
spend a day with me because I've been
thrown under the bus by these guys who
have been in my home many times but like
I watched him for a while and I was like
he seems decent enough he's just he was
on my podcast and he's great and he's
been checking in with me during this
Twitter I hate us and said I was
essentially bananas but art was the one
who I was we were talking about this you
know do I have anything to lose and I
said well I the hard thing for me being
off Twitter is that I really can trace
every single dollar that I make through
Twitter whether it's through an editor
who found me
that's how playboy originally found me
that's how I most of my patrons come
through Twitter and he said really
you're just a drug addict that started
cooking meth in your basement
oh no but I do I wouldn't have met art
so there is this again I'm optimistic I
think that we there's this double-edged
sort of like we are connected and we
have the conversations that are
happening on podcasts that you have that
Joe Rogan's having I know you guys are
all paying the price for it I cannot
tell you how many men have told me
Jordan Peterson literally save their
life whatever they want to think about
him he's helping people in a really
tangible way and that is that is up
that's that is hopeful for me however
when I see that there are less and less
outlets for this that the gatekeepers
seem to be you know shutting down like
no conservative columnist if you're a
leftist publication the stuff I've seen
in terms of D platform
patreon I mean I shed lots of people lie
about that I know we heard all our
friends I've had a lot of Mike because
but some of my friends are still out
there and browsing and it's like I in
that regard I kind of feel bad because
we because Jordan Sam and I leaving did
cause like this like little guys like
ran so I can try to see my friend
there's some things coming I mean
there's at least two things coming
I hope so really big and hopefully sobs
on these problems yeah there that's what
worries me is that I do I do believe
that being able to have hard
conversations talk about things hear
those things that you don't want to hear
but be able to listen to them know who
is saying those things I want to know I
don't want them to have to go
underground and start groups and you
know thank you whatever they need to do
know have good crazy YouTube channel but
then again I question the you know that
what recently happened in New Zealand
these things that would generally be
contained to small little groups in like
basement somewhere and now do have a
platform to kind of spread these ideas
quickly well it was so interesting
because the in the manifesto he's
basically saying he wants to start this
war right and then what does everyone do
on both sides they just start handing it
to him and blame people blaming this
person this person and blaming this
person and everyone calling each other
Nazis and it's like you guys literally
what you're outsourcing your brains to
people that are truly truly dangerous
yeah you're saying to anyone that's out
there do something crazy right something
crazy and we're all gonna pay attention
to it it's like the worst that's a good
point
really is the worst possible thing you
can do it and itself there's a lot of
what I worried about I wrote this piece
for Playboy actually they let me write
it and it was a Donald Trump is already
making America great again
and I put it out on an inauguration it
was probably a little too soon for
people to hear the message but
essentially was looking at the silver
lining and I said in it I worry about
the self-fulfilling prophecy that ever
you know there's a great quote in that
show Deadwood and he the doctor says
I've seen more harm done with a man
trying to justify themselves than a man
seeking to do harm and this is what
worries me and what I see where it's
like you would rather have him be in
collusion with Russia you would rather
have him like be a Nazi or whatever so
that you can be right
like that's dangerous because in effect
you're saying you'd rather us be in
World War three right because if you'd
cool so that you can be right yeah like
guys some of these things are good that
they're not true but that's bad and you
know I again I'm very much about doing
work on yourself and keeping yourself in
check and that is something I constantly
have to keep even with like the Jesse's
one thing it's always all along I was
like something ain't right about this
but the media goes all-in on it the
candidates the Democratic candidates all
said what evidence of our evil racist
country this is I'm sure some of them
haven't even deleted the tweets but then
today's news yeah it was basically
everything dropped yeah but as you were
holding this for a couple days so it was
a few days ago that yeah that the
charges against him were all dropped
right and it's like what power these
charges dropped there's the guys there's
the video of the guys picking up the
news but I had to check myself during
that process to make sure that I wasn't
just excited that I wasn't so excited to
be right that I wasn't overlooking the
fact that maybe he was actually this
thing that actually happened I still
don't think it did yeah but in through
that whole process you know I think it's
this is where I think each individual it
falls on us to do our due diligence on
not just the news and our sources of
news but on ourselves and how much are
we hoping for something so that we can
be right that's something I think we all
have to especially I would say to my
friends on the left
really look at that like it's it's good
that even when it came out that he may
be faked a crime against himself like
it's good that these guys aren't walking
around Chicago beating people that's a
good thing but in a weird way they need
to be a Russian now Russia if they meet
right for their narrative they need the
Jessie smell app thing to be real to
prove that Americans races and these
things consistently prove not to be real
but let's shift a little bit because you
you write all sorts of things and I
usually dive into the topics that are
the most controversial that'll get you
off twitter pretty quick you just wrote
this piece about you don't have to go to
college basically wasting your money
wasting your money I don't think that
was very popular yeah you did that in
The Spectator pretty recently and the
idea was that there are ways to get jobs
in the future trade schools and all
sorts of other things yeah that maybe
you don't need this brainwashing
experience for four years yes I was
speaking with Carol Roth and she's
brilliant and very into finance and you
know she made we were talking about this
and she said just the idea that it's
like the return on investment for six
figures for a five figure return a mess
if it just doesn't make sense and I can
only speak from personal experience and
I for some people college is what you
need to do if you're gonna specialize I
my argument is that the automatic just
go to college mentality and then getting
out with this enormous amount of debt so
that you can figure out what you want to
do that's an expensive way to figure out
what you want to do and I realize this
pretty quickly into my first year of
college my I would got after my first
semester I saw my loans and the debt
that I was already in after one semester
and I always wanted to be a writer and I
was like well I know how to write so I I
don't need to spend four years doing
this and then get out and have debt and
then have to take jobs that I hate
taking and be miserable so that I can
pay off my debt or when I was working up
on a goat farm in Northern California
there was a girl who
why were the quotes around it was like
the long-term joke I told my family I
was working on ago farm and they've you
know like a Humboldt County and there
was a lot of people there who basically
they it was not in their benefit to go
into the workforce above you know they
were working under the table obviously
because then it didn't trigger their
student loans so there's like the
deferment and I'm like what you you're
an engineer why are you sitting here
with me and I think that there are a
million ways to skin a cat you know you
we need trade workers we need we need
just so many different laborers and I've
gotten a lot of criticism for this
article and a lot of it is fair but is
it also that we just don't need certain
things that people are being taught it's
not only that we need people that have
certain skills like physical skills but
it's also that a lot of the stuff that
people are majoring in college if you're
majoring in you know feminist dance or
lesbian that no I mean you know any of
these things it's like okay well what do
you think you just paid for for all of
those years yeah and I think I said and
he's like you're if you go get a degree
in gender studies you're really only
good for writing blogs on the internet
like that's bad but what else are you
gonna do with that maybe your teach what
really what you teach gender studies
that's what you do what do you do though
I mean what do you do with that degree
so be practical about the I'm I
generally because I have had to pay for
it I didn't have if your starts paying
for college or whatever go go to college
get a degree there's a lot the pushback
I've I've received that has been the
most thoughtful is that statistically
people die sooner if they don't go to
college now I would think I think this
probably has a lot to do with
socioeconomic factors that are not
necessarily being taken to the causation
correlation right but there yeah exactly
it but I everybody went to college so
it's also
a study that you're like well there's an
entire generation of people that went to
college what about a generation of
people who maybe when became trade
workers and maybe they went and whatever
learnt taught themselves how to code
online which is what my another family
member of mine did there's so many it
also sounds like a new version of like
like servitude to me like when when
Bernie gets out there and he's like free
college for everyone which we no of
course no is not free and then he says a
guarantee of a federal job that sounds
horrible to me so if we're gonna for I
mean in effect you're gonna force
everyone to go to college because the
few people who won't want it will be
shamed into doing it and wasting their
time when they probably have all sorts
of other skills and can do all you know
they can write without go to school they
can learn how to do coding or whatever
else learn to code I don't know if I
even look but like and then the
guarantee is that you'll get a federal
job that's out god or you can be a
pencil pusher for the government with no
real chance of ever growing but you know
you'll never be fired so you just stay
there forever and just some money off
other people I'm not a genius by any
means but I know I don't I don't want to
work for the government I don't want
them to have much of my money doing
things with they just don't seem to be
that effective from every government
institution I've had to deal with yeah
well you gotta love it the lefties Trump
is Hitler there were the government's
evil the patriarchy patriarchy what's
their answer more money give them more
money I had it I got into it with a
friend about this the other night and I
felt bad because we hadn't talked in a
while and I didn't realize that he he
was um as fully indoctrinated in the
approved message as he was and I really
just tend to ask questions and it's
amazing how angry he was getting at my
questions he said you know I'm tired of
all these white supremacists talking
they can all just shut up and I said
okay but why do you want to change your
gut like why do you want to give away
your gun saying cuz anyone's up on a
tangent about that and I'm like I just
want to know the logic that's it and you
find that it ever gets to a logical
point because I I've had these
conversations with friends and now
sometimes former friends yeah yeah our
friends yeah but do you ever find it
like there's they always move the
goalposts they always change the
definition of words or they change how
history is like do you ever find in one
of those conversations you can get it to
something that has some shape we had you
know he the conversation started because
I made the mistake of telling him that I
was doing the Glenn Beck radio show and
I didn't even think twice about it
because I'm used to now I a Q PI a space
that's a little bit more centrist and so
I got I got I got lazy and I got I was
laughing and he just like lost it on me
I was like you're going on the and I
said I will have this conversation when
anyone who's willing to have a
conversation with me about this what was
his implication that come back as a
white supremacist well yeah obviously
anyone now that that the whole I and
this is why I'm not sure how we escaped
from this binary and I was writing about
this yesterday in my journal I can't
write on Twitter it ya know if you want
me at the end of this if you want me to
tweet out to angry powerful for you
screenshots of my journal yeah please
help me know I was writing about how
because I'm making I always try to make
sure that I keep myself a breast of the
of whatever is being written on the left
as well and I I'm not sure how you
escape the binary of essentially the
Republican Party is the party of white
supremacy and if you are a conservative
or a Republican you are basically doing
everything to uphold white supremacy and
you're not saying that's true you're
just saying that you're saying this is
this seems to be what the messaging is
the
as I understand it I could be wrong but
this seems to be what I'm reading and
and what I when I'm hearing and I don't
know how you escape that binary well I
think you relentlessly have to call
these people out I mean that that's all
you can do it's just not the case it's
just not true but they own so much of
the media and so much right academia and
everything else that these messages keep
coming through and now you've got a
friend of yours probably telling you
you're a white supremacist I'm gonna
Glenn Beck I was I was a white
supremacist for doing ben Shapiro's
elections special I mean that was he a
white supremacist likes more than an
orthodox apparently apparently you can
that that can be the case and so that
that's um I recently I mean I stepped
into I stepped into it and it was my own
fault
I hadn't had coffee and I was tweeting
recklessly and I I said something I came
in defense of that white kid that was on
the GQ cover and I was an ice up like
the war on white men and I meant to put
quotes on it because yeah and I didn't
know coffee and this is not excuse that
it was like early and I was like oh
there's not enough space what could
possibly go wrong and not thinking and I
got it was like two days of your garbage
essentially your garbage I got called
the Grand Wizard and it is weird when
you're you know being called racist used
to be like the worst insult and I grew
up learning that that was a horrible
insult and so to have that and somebody
kind of stepped James Lindsay actually
step ten and he was like Bridget I see
what's happening here you are up against
you know like critical theory and you
need to just like log out and say
nothing because it will all be used as
proof that you are a racist essentially
yeah and it was you know there's parts
of it that were upsetting obviously and
then parts of it I was like this is not
why are you calling regard badge would
you say that's my face yeah well they're
anonymous
and they're on Twitter during that these
were blue checks like they were yeah it
was a what do you make let's just back
up to this point that the like because I
saw this happening on Twitter that there
were journalists actually trying to stop
you from writing a piece where do you
what do you think about just the state
of journalism cuz to me to me at the
moment especially after the last you
know little time with the Muller
investigation anything like it's over it
really like CNN and MSNBC whatever shred
of remote credibility they have left
they've destroyed the New York Times is
basically destroying itself I don't say
any of that with pleasure
people think I'm saying it like haha
okay i if those guys could just be a
little bit better but they can't or just
a force myself or flip or just instead
of doubling down every time right like
now now they're all trying to throw
mueller under the bus because he didn't
do exactly what they wanted and now
we've got to instigate investigate him
and just more government everywhere and
it's like what are you guys chasing you
chasing your own shadow
it's the state of journalism is is very
worrisome to me because it and i do
sometimes wonder about journalists on
twitter because you need it in one
respect but on the other respect you see
everyone's politics so how could
anything that you they wrote be unbiased
you know where everyone's coming from
and i do wonder to do you know matt um
how do you say his last name to be
Taibbi Taibbi he wrote a piece a couple
of about nothing yeah
about yeah and just the state of
journalism and he's been doing some
really great reporting actual
journalistic reporting and he listed all
of the links to every single thing that
all of these organizations CNN and the
New York Times have said and he compares
it to the WMD you know he I think he
there are still journalists who are
critical of their fellow journalists and
the criticism that came to me when I
reached out for self censorship was like
oh here comes Bridget writing another
piece about how Trump supporters are
self-censored know actually quite the
contrary that's not what I'm looking for
I'm I'm
how liberals are self-censoring and they
don't want to hear it
generally somebody said you know and you
get the most flack when you're over the
target yeah and I definitely just the
fact that everyone piled on they don't
they do not want to hear how they might
be pushing their own party away people
in their party and these are the people
that they need there's no more votes to
the left to the far left you've gone as
far as left as you can go boys and girls
aren't different anymore we can't go any
further
well that's why they want to lower the
voting age to 16 though because they
know I mean really that's it but lower
the voting age change the electoral
college and members of the Supreme Court
I mean these are all ideas that are
being floated by them right now because
yes there's no that that intersectional
competing interest cacophony can't hold
forever you run come back a little bit
and be somewhat reasonable if only
somebody had been talking about this for
these last five years yeah what you
failed my friend do you feel like people
are from the left's are kind of waking
up as well or do you feel like there
just is the cognitive justice just like
I need to just I would double down yeah
the core of the left where the energy of
the left is so like Cortes and Omer and
that whole new crew and the Democratic
socialists we're only holding on to the
word democratic for another year or two
and then they'll just be socialists I
think they've got all the energy they've
got they feel like they have the young
people they certainly have the woke
media and what's happening is and this
is why I'm actually hopeful because you
said you're an optimist I always say I'm
a world-weary optimist it's like I
believe that yeah they can keep doing
that and they will implode on itself
you're gonna have to take down Bernie
one day he's an old white man yo you'll
destroy each other but what I think
mostly will happen is the decent
liberals like yourself will just more
and more realize that there is something
happening center-right right now that
it's not racist that is based on freedom
and liberty and individual rights and is
respectful of differences and there's
some pro-choice people there and some
pro-life people and some gay people and
straight people and I think that's where
the the
I think that's the if America will
continue as a great nation and a free
nation that's the future of it the other
thing they're not going to stop
they can't stop they've had so many
chances to stop Trump president yeah
that seems like it would have been a
reason to reflect no this is the crazy
thing is that the conversation with my
friend who might not any be my friend
anymore he said well he's not gonna win
and like yeah I hear this all the time
from people how can you say that he won
you're saying to me the exact same thing
that you said in 2016 that you said was
impossible you're saying it's impossible
again like how are you saying this ha
cognitive dissonance I don't understand
I don't understand that that's where I'm
that's where I just I'm like okay
bye-bye
I try to be I listen but there are
certain things where I'm I'm like I
don't understand how you can think
that's a logical thought to have there's
no chance that's impossible yeah the
thing that just had the thing that just
happened that you said was impossible
and he said well you have to understand
bridges that when you say that's people
you are basically [ __ ] on all of
their hope and I'm like well okay so now
it's my responsibility to take care of
everyone else in the world's feelings
and this is the new thing where you're
supposed to just manage everyone in the
world's one of the first things I
learned in rehab when I was 19 is that
it's none of my business how anyone
feels about me yeah and now it's like
apparently I have to make sure everyone
around me is okay and because then you
can never think about yourself and
that's really what they don't want it's
it's interest that's what they really
want they don't want you to be able to
think about what you really think so
they keep you focused on everybody else
all the time yeah I mean it's I think
we're living and I mix I think it's
times that we live I love it I think
it's exciting and I think it's dangerous
and terrifying as well and there are
days you know when I was getting these
emails about how people self-censor it
was I was in a dark place and my cousin
came over Maggie and she said we need
F out of us Lake hole you're in because
it was hundreds of hundreds of emails
but the language people are using thank
you for giving me permission to speak
freely thank you for allowing me to I
don't know if this will end up anywhere
but it just feels so good to get that
out and these they assume there are
these things of people saying you know
the some of the people on the left
trolled me and had no they were like
these intentionally racist things but
mostly emails I got were very thoughtful
and very you know places there's people
are well it's not people that are
staking out far-right positions I think
is what you're saying yeah no that are
just saying maybe I'm for low taxes or
something and they're afraid to say it
because you're gonna owe your
conservative yeah job yeah and also just
the way that it's infecting policy like
you say you'd like we've been set on
here and people say that the politics
are downstream of culture so just the
way that one man was saying well it's we
really are afraid to criticize the code
of certain hires because it could you
end you up in HR and so and he's like
and this is code that's kind of
important these are the soft effects of
you know on the marketplace and then the
world of ideas that we can't see that
were and you can really only see if you
ask for people to be truly honest and
fearless or if people start speaking up
but you you're not gonna see that
because it's so subtle it's so insidious
that's the thing about self-censorship
it's so it starts you know it starts in
the mind and then and once you start
doing it you just keep going it's almost
impossible to remember that original
person and it's easier to for instance
you can't burn a book if you get it
banned before it's even published I mean
these are thing
that I deeply concern me there it more
concerning I feel like there's a lot of
corruption and stuff that that we have
to take aim it you know I feel like it's
our job as citizens and this is really
my my big where I stand now is kind of
with you I guess in the middle and
saying like the center must hold we I
had abandoned my job as a citizen of
looking critically at everybody and the
fact that somebody like myself or you
who might be looking critically at
things on the right and critically on
things on the right that's controversial
is is very bad news for democracy
because that is our job as citizens not
to be loyal to some party it's to be
critical of our leaders and all the
people who want to be leaders not just
like on some team this isn't like the
Red Sox and the Yankees I mean you
shouldn't automatically vote for whoever
Katy Perry likes
I mean Taylor Swift silence is that we
are gonna do this many times more oh
yeah I have no doubt I'm glad we finally
did yeah thank you we need people like
you out there doing this stuff we need
straight white heterosexual cisgendered
chicks I mean that's basically what you
are I just think people need to know
they're not alone yeah I think a lot of
people when I've realized from the self
censorship people think they're alone
they're not alone if you're a reasonable
person out there and you're feeling like
you're going crazy you're not alone and
you there's a you know reach out to you
email me whatever if you feel if you're
in the dark place yeah find find others
who you can speak freely with and have
conversations with because I think that
is important yeah well that's why I'm
doing stand-up again and we gotta go
we'll do a gig together yeah let's do
something together because that's the
point of it yeah I'm just messing around
with the crowd we get in that room and
we just kind of know fine it's like I
want people to look around the room and
be like yeah guess what that guy likes
Trump you like Bernie it's okay we're
not killing each other
so we're gonna do it yeah it'd be great
yeah all right well you guys can follow
Bridget on Twitter it's at Bridget fed
Izzy although you will be talking to
cousin Maggie but she's she's a lovely
woman she's amazing amazing we love you
Maggie
[Music]